all right beginning of a new video which
means before we get started i want to
thank the sponsor of this video this
video is brought to you by dr squatch dr
squatch is changing the way men approach
hygiene their shower soap leaves you
feeling refreshed feeling clean but most
importantly they're all about being
natural their shower soap doesn't
contain any of the harmful chemicals a
lot of soaps out there use and they
don't just have shower stuff they have
some other stuff that they did send me
shampoo and conditioner deodorant beard
oil they sent me beard oil i'm telling
you you grow a beard you get more
freebies with sponsorships it's lost
they did send me a couple new soaps to
use but it kind of doesn't matter
because i already had these in my
cupboard because i bought them because i
actually love their product which is why
when they wanted to do another
sponsorship with me i was like easy yes
so click the link below and new
customers get 20 off your orders of 20
or more when you use promo code dsc
john's thank you once again to dr squash
for sponsoring this video i do
appreciate it alright and now it
this movie was a surprise i gotta say
[Music]
so cop shop is an all-out very
self-aware very fun movie starring
alexis louder i know you look at the
poster you're like oh it stars gerard
butler and frank grillo it does in that
han solo is also a star of star wars
multiple main characters near the point
of the conflict of the movie frank
grillo's character is a person that some
very powerful people want daddy's in
this holding cell in this little county
jail in the middle of bfe gerard butler
is a person who's in another holding
cell and he's there to kill him and at
that point it's kind of like assault on
precinct 13 minus the assault really
it's not like armies of people are
trying to get into this jail to kill
this guy most of the people are going to
be at work in this scenario are already
in there the movie's directed by joe
carnahan so right there you hear the
premise you're like okay so some of that
smoking aces flavor but it is executed
differently i appreciate that it's not
just oh smoking aces
alexis louder's character is the cop
were following through this crazy bat
[ __ ] scenario and right when i saw her
like when you first meet her i was like
i love her it was probably the fact that
she just gushes about her single action
revolver and i don't disagree with her
absolutely revolver ocelot metal gear
solid amazing character for a myriad of
reasons one of which is his choice of
firearms she's what we call lawful good
she's a good cop and when in doubt the
law is the thing that you know that
that's where her compass points in a
scenario like this there's one moment in
particular where she just has to make a
decision and neither of which are
actually in accordance with the law
that's interesting to me i did i loved
the fact that you see the conflict on
her face and i don't know what i would
have picked i'd have picked the wrong
scenario i'd have picked the wrong
decision at first i loved the quippy
attitude coming from her then i realized
that's just a lot of people in this
script do have that but they have it in
ways that work with their personalities
specifically it's not like they're just
cookie cutters like okay quippy person a
quippy person b quippy person c no very
different personalities still shine
through in this movie full of a lot of
big personalities i just thought the
characters were a lot of fun and the
actors in this movie were having fun
playing them just that one scene from
the trailer you see it on gerard
butler's face somebody help this man
he's gonna die
part of the fun i had with this movie
was probably i saw no trailers for it i
saw no advertisements for it i was just
kind of like all right what's the movie
this week oh thursday night movie here
it is but in the fact that i had not
seen the trailer for this movie i knew
nothing about the characters or the
premise of this movie i knew nothing
about toby huss or the character he
played in this movie i had no idea that
just when you think all the fun [ __ ] is
already happening and all the pieces of
the puzzle are at work you get this new
character it just adds a whole new
element now it's one of those movies it
happens every couple years or so there's
that one movie where maybe you don't
know much about it maybe you think it
might suck you walk out and you're like
that was way better than i thought it
was going to be or at least more fun
this is probably the most fun i've had
in a movie in 2021
top two actually but before i get the
comments and people like i guess he
forgot about this movie let me go
through the rolodex of movies i've seen
in 2021 oh that one was sweet too yeah
safe to say in terms of fun characters
quippy dialogues some [ __ ] talk and gun
fights that i like this is this is up
there also though i said firefight it
doesn't use that it's just okay we'll
fill the time really if you look at it
they were very sparingly used and only
really in the second half of the movie
the rest of the movie really did a good
job at building tension and the humor
and [ __ ] talk in this movie didn't
compromise that tension and the fact
that this movie takes place in the
police precinct for 98 of it i think
that's a huge reason that the tension in
this movie works not every movie that
attempts the whole the movie takes place
in one location thing pulls it off but
if they do pull it off that single
location shtick is a large reason why i
personally count this movie among the
successes where's my number one critique
gripe or otherwise [ __ ] about the movie
thing was the movie too long yeah a
little bit
they always are but this movie did have
like that moment where you're like okay
movie ended and i got up i'm on my way
out and the movie was like no no it's
not like this is a post credit scene or
anything this is just the movie's still
going it's that jack putter to the
rescue moment at the end of inner space
only just a lot more drawn out could
have just you know sped that one up a
bit or maybe not even had the moment for
this movie what i can say about this
movie is well [ __ ] done glad i
watched it gonna buy it on blu-ray all
right so cop shop have you seen it what
did you think about it or what's a movie
that you didn't know anything about and
you saw it or maybe you thought it was
gonna suck and then you saw it either
case you walked out of the movie theater
completely surprised or your living room
wherever you saw the movie but whatever
that movie is whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]
you